hello to you good morning k
good morning to you how proud would your
sister be of you this morning
she'd be incredibly proud joe always
used to say to me you need to push
yourself more you need to challenge
yourself more
and she would be extremely proud you
thanked the police in your victory
speech
how nasty was the campaign for you
sadly we had some pretty ugly scenes
last weekend uh during the campaign
um i was subjected to personal abuse and
intimidation and sadly people who were
helping me with a campaign
um had similar um i think even someone
got even arrested
and it's really sad that we had that
because i tried to conduct a really
positive campaign
full of energy all about the people of
batley and spain so it was very
upsetting to see that
kind of divisiveness creeping into our
politics again
how disappointed were you uh not to have
a much
bigger majority i mean 3 23
is is how many you won by i mean with
323 you could have lost by 323 couldn't
you it's not a resounding success
a win is a win and i'll take that every
day of the week it was always going to
be close
you know apollo 6 is tough at the minute
um but i think i i'm really pleased with
the win that we've had
we were chatting to amanda milling i
don't know if you if you heard her a
second or two ago conservative party
co-chair and she admitted that the matt
hancock effect had
uh had an impact on their vote is that
what you were hearing on the on the
doorstep do you know what
the vast majority of conversations i've
had with people have been about local
issues
and i think lots of people have tried to
make this about other things that are
going on at a national level
but what most people in between spain
wanted was an mp
who is local who cares about this area
and understands
the issues that they're concerned about
and because i live here and i've lived
here all my life i think that really
resonated with people
uh why did george galloway do so well
i think we've got communities across
valley and spain
who um are sadly a bit disillusioned
with politics
and disillusioned with traditional sort
of politicians
one of the things i really want to focus
on is how we get people engaged with
politics in a positive way
and i think sometimes you know we've had
people come here this by-election with
their own agendas and their own egos
um and i've played into people's
frustrations
and my job now is to bring those people
together
around a shared vision for a prosperous
and bright future for valley and spain
he says he's going to contend the result
what you can test the result what do you
think
listen i'm focused on the rest of my day
which is celebrating with an amazing
team
who have supported me throughout this
campaign uh getting back in touch with
my family and friends who i've barely
seen during the last few weeks
um and then cracking on with the job of
being the mp for ballet and spain
yeah i mean he did take 22 percent of
the vote didn't he and that was on an
anti-labor stance it does look as though
uh much of the
muslim community as was uh supporting
him
rather than you what do you need to do
to bring them back into the fold
i've spent the last few years working
for the joe cox foundation uh building
communities across badly in spain and
indeed at a national level
um and i'll continue to do that and i
think sadly the divisive nature of
other people's campaigns um means that
that word
work still needs to be done but if
anyone can do it then i believe that i
can do it
supported by the you know the majority
of people in battle and spain
who just want to live together
peacefully send their kids to school
have a good nhs
look after their elderly relatives and
you know and and and just get on with
their lives and i think that's what we
all want to do now you know we've had
a lot of attention in battle and
spending the last few weeks indeed in
the last few years
and i think we just need now a bit of
stability and hopefully i can be part of
that
and what do the people of batley and
spend think of kia stammer
again most of the conversations i've had
with people have been very very
localized
uh cares coming up later on today and
it'll be wonderful to to celebrate with
him
um so i think you know let's move
forward now as a labour party
with keira at the helm with me as the
new mp for batley and spen and i think
have that sense of togetherness within
the party
that we've had during this campaign
because it's been really really powerful
and i have been so well supported
uh by this party um and the values of
the labor party that have connected with
people i think given us the victory
around you know equality and fairness
and social justice i think
you know there's a piece of work to be
done but i feel really proud to be part
of that
um what's the first thing that you plan
to do when you come to the palace of
westminster
um i need to um meet all the many people
who have supported me during this
campaign you know i've had so many
labour mps have come up here to to meet
me and
and and support me so i want to go down
and say a massive thank you to them
and then i want to crack on with the
work you know and that really is
is about getting on with the issues that
people have raised on the doorsteps
looking at how that plays out at a local
level and
at a national level um so there's a lot
to be done once i've said thank you to
all the many people who've helped me
once i've seen my family and friends
then you know i'm going to hit the
ground running
yeah i'm just looking at uh the number
of elections that the people of batley
and spen
have had to deal with five elections in
the past
six years um it's been quite a roller
coaster for them
is it going to be a bit more stable now
i really do hope so okay as someone who
lives here
you know we have been through the mill
um and
it is disruptive you know and like i say
we've got a lovely selection of towns
and villages across batley and spain
where
where people just want to get on with
their lives and when the media descends
and when people from out of this area
descend
it is disruptive it's not good for
people so i'm really hoping that
we have a period of calm we have a
period of stability and and my role as
our mp will
will be pivotal in that but you know the
people around here are just amazing the
conversations i've had with people of
this
campaign have been so powerful and you
know i'm really looking forward to
working
together with them on what matters to
our towns and villagers
what did your parents say when or what
did the family say
when you said that you wanted to to run
uh
as an mp given what happened to joe in
such a tragic way when she was
representing the people of bethlehem
it was a big team decision it was a big
family decision
um but you know mum and dad have seen
the work that i've done through the
foundation
they've seen the network that i've got
across our local area
and how powerful that can be and a way
to build on that work
is by being our mp and they were very
very supportive of that and they always
said as well you know
if you don't do it you might regret not
going for it you know whatev whatever
happens
and yeah it was a team decision and
it's very emotional for us as a family
of course it is um
but listen if i can be half the mp that
joe was then i'll be very very happy and
very very proud of that
and will there be parts of joe that you
want to bring
to westminster do you i mean obviously
we know that you're
joe's sister you also want to be your
own person when you come to the palace
of westminster
but other uh characteristics of her that
you'll bring along with you for your
maiden speech for example
yeah i mean i'm kim ledbeter i am joe
cox's sister and that's how lots of
people know me and i've never been more
proud to be so but i
am doing this job very much as me one
thing i would say though is the way that
joe worked on a cross-party basis i
think is something which i always
admired and respected and i think
we don't do enough of that and we don't
talk enough about that you know the mps
that i've met and know
a lot of cross-party work goes on behind
the scenes but because it always isn't
as quite as controversial as
some of the other stuff it doesn't get
covered in the way that it maybe should
do
so i'll be looking to work on a
cross-party basis with
anybody who who is happy to do that on
the issues that matter to the people of
batley and spen
and the issues that matter more broadly
to the country okay
congratulations well done i know you've
got a lot to do today including uh being
congratulated
by the leader of the party try and get
some sleep at some stage but thanks for
talking to us
thanks for talking i will thank uk